[Musik]
manchmal ist es schwierig einen schritt
zurückzugehen und das gesamtbild zu
betrachten denn so normal unser alltag
auch vorkommen mag was jetzt gerade
passiert ist alles andere als normal
wir befinden uns in einem zeitalter
exponentiellen fortschritt jedes jahr
werden unsere smartphones so und so viel
prozent schneller haben eine kamera mit
ex prozent mehr auflösung oder können so
und so viele stunden länger durchhalten
jedes jahr kommen neue elektroautos auf
den markt die weiterfahren und schneller
aufladen können als ihre vorgänger
jedes jahr werden sich neue
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse
veröffentlicht neue medikamente auf den
markt gebracht und jedes jahr werden
fünf neue durchbrüche der wissenschaft
mit einem nobelpreis geehrt
das ist für uns normal der fortschritt
schreitet nur mal vor aber stellt euch
mal für eine sekunde die alternative vor
stellt euch vor die menschheit würde
stillstehen wir würden den status quo
akzeptieren und nicht mehr forschen
nicht mehr neugierig seien nichts neues
mehr ausprobieren wie würde unsere welt
dann aussehen
das motion gesetz besagt dass sich die
leistung von mikroprozessoren alle zwei
jahre verdoppelt und seit gordon nur
dies 1965 postulierte ist es mehr oder
weniger genau so eingetreten
seit über 50 jahren steigt die leistung
von prozessoren exponentiell an das hier
ist eine logarithmische skalierung die
lineare kurve sieht man fast nie weil
das exponentielle wachstum sie quasi
unbrauchbar macht so unglaublich
leistungsstark sind prozessoren
inzwischen geworden
aber hier ist etwas das viele nicht über
das muschel gesetz wissen es ist gar
kein gesetz das gravitationsgesetz gilt
egal ob es menschen gibt die daran
glauben oder nicht
aber wenn die vielen unzähligen menschen
die täglich am mikro chips arbeiten von
heute auf morgen damit aufhören dann
würde auch das muschel gesetz aufhören
zu stimmen
fortschritt ist nichts was von alleine
passiert
er entsteht dadurch dass unzählige
menschen jeden tag forscher
experimentieren hart arbeiten und immer
wieder scheitern bis sie einen
durchbruch erreicht haben übrigens das
ende des motion gesetzes wurde schon
unzählige male vorausgesagt quasi seit
nur das erste mal davon sprach bis heute
aber bisher gab es immer physiker
ingenieure programmierer
materialwissenschaftler und noch
zigtausende weitere forscherinnen und
forscher dieses auf sich genommen haben
das unmögliche möglich zu machen nämlich
die transistoren auf einem chip noch
weiter zu verkleinern
die leistung noch und noch einmal zu
verdoppeln jede generation hat auf dem
wissen der vorangegangenen aufgebaut und
neue tricks neue ideen entwickelt und
genau das werden wir auch in zukunft
weiter tun
xenon plasma 3d stacking und neue
materialien wie graphit oder kohlenstoff
nanoröhren selbst die juwele tu graz
wurde viele jahrzehnte als unmöglich
abgetan und wird nun gerade serienreif
gemacht und so wie mikrochips immer
schneller immer effizienter immer
ausgeklügelter werden verhält es sich
mit vielen dingen am 9 oktober 1903
trieb die new york times dass der mensch
in den nächsten eine million jahren
nicht fliegen können wird aber noch im
selben jahr hatten die gebrüder wright
genau das daraufhin folgten düsenjets
passagier flugzeuge hubschrauber und
schließlich raketen
heute stehen wir kurz davor den ersten
motorisierten flug auf einem anderen
planeten durchzuführen
und all das passierte weil wir neugierig
waren und uns gefragt haben ja was wäre
wenn wir doch fliegen könnten
neugier ist der grund dafür dass der
mensch das feuer entdeckt hat dass wir
begannen werkzeuge zu benutzen um
unseren alltag zu erleichtern
das rad um dinge zu transportieren und
die sonne nur um die zeit zu messen
schießpulver die druckpresse die
dampfmaschine die glühbirne auto radio
fernsehen raketen internet smartphones
was werden wir noch alles erreichen wenn
wir uns die richtigen fragen stellen wie
wollen wir miteinander leben können wir
künstliche intelligenz erschaffen oder
uns vielleicht selber verbessern
wie können wir unseren planeten retten
können wir vielleicht auf einem anderen
planeten leben oder auf dem mond im
weltall
was passiert in einem schwarzen loch was
war vor dem urknall und sind im
universum allein
[Musik]
das alles alles was wir im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert als
selbstverständlich betrachten ist
möglich durch neugierde durch forschung
durch wissenschaft die größte erfindung
der menschheit könnte man argumentieren
ist nicht das rad oder das internet
sondern unsere wissenschaftlichen
methoden unsere art und weise wissen zu
sammeln
wissenschaft ist ständig um uns herum
sie ist die sprache mit der wie das
universum verstehen sie dir die welt aus
einem anderen blickwinkel an und fragt
sich warum ist das so schnell eine
hypothese auf versuch vorherzusagen wie
sich etwas verhalten wird und danach ein
experiment dokumentiert und analysiert
eine ergebnisse und formuliere deine
hypothese um das ist wissenschaft das
ist erkenntnis wir müssen nur hinschauen
zu hören aufpassen und versuchen zu
verstehen
in diesem sinne bleibt neugierig patrick